les cherry hill et leur hisser le moment
d'accueillir celle qui va donner le coup
d'envoi
le coup d'envoi de cette onzième saison
elle est là elle vient d'arriver on me
le dire priorité au direct et qui elle
est là ce soir expressément pour nous
elle est à paris pour quelques jours on
a vu sur les réseaux sociaux
son nouveau petit copain elle est avec
nous ce soir
tout à l'heure du rail gérard depardieu
à vous dire voilà qui sera là hélas non
on avait une soeur kylie jenner non non
avec le jura bull minutes pour donner le
coup d'envoi
là on rêve seront alors elle va elle va
très vite a pas donné le coup d'envoi de
la 11e saison honnête avec nous c'est
qui s'est amorcée combien aussi d'avant
mais sur lequel vont pas de la brousse
[Applaudissements]
c'est certainement la plus grande star
mondiale
elle nous fait l'honneur d'être avec
nous ce soir kylie jenner pour donner le
coup d'envoi de cette onzième saison d'à
voulu taper très fort gérard depardieu
le patron le taulier donc pour premiers
invités touche pas à mon poste et kylie
jenner qui étaient avec nous on va aller
la chercher
kylie qui va donner le coup d'envoi de
la 11e saison messieurs on va pas la
faire attendre plus longtemps
merci applaudissements pour elle elle
est là ce soir car il est une heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez moi c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
m'avait vendu c'est qu'il est bouder
sans galères de budget pourquoi vous
reconnaitre merci j'avais un texte mais
fait rigoler lui c'est normal je suis
très content d'être ici donc la kalina
vrai pour des raisons budgétaires
oui elle peut pas venir oui mais voilà
on appris à kylie de tiddis clash
allocataires je voulais absolument qu'il
soit avec nous pour cette voie là il
passe une tête parce que c était je suis
pas plus belle que kylie sakhaline des
grandes stars pour nous l'année dernière
il a fait une année exceptionnelle il
sera avec moi dans la grande rue à la
grosse rigolade bien entendu et vous
derrière son livre qui sort il va faire
l'émission avec moi cette semaine je
crois il est calé oui on a voté et sa
fille chez moi comme en foot c'est que
je t'aime mais je crois qu'on a mais
j'ai quand même jetés ramener mieux que
kylie
c'est vrai non mais là c'est pas une
blague alors il ya gérard depardieu qui
mènera le vrai tout à l'heure voilà le
vrai ou faux j'ai envie d'aller au stade
j'ai un message de quelqu'un qu'on adore
tous et c'est encore mieux que kylie
alors jobin je vous laisse le découvrir
c'est parti enfin peut-être
[Applaudissements]
je remercie à jeff pettis heller six ans
paul belmondo qui donne le coup d'envoi
de cette nouvelle saison
on est content jean paul belmondo ouest
du message et gérard depardieu qui sera
tout à l'heure jean paul tu sais que je
t'aime fort et j'espère te voir très
vite voilà tu sais que tu es voilà et
voilà je suis fou de toi merci mon
bouder